foreign
let's go right to the phones let's go to
Frank in Philadelphia where he was born
and raised what's up Frank
how we doing
I'm doing pretty good pretty good good
man what's up how can we help
uh yeah so I'm about I'm about 90 000 in
a school loan debt I did underground I
also did well I'm also currently doing
graduate now I'm I'm about finished with
uh with my graduate school what are you
studying man
I'm studying I'm studying my Master's in
business management
uh now uh and my undergraduate was in
was in media studies and production
what do you want to do Frank after grad
school
uh I wanted to open up my own
photography company but uh but I'm
learning now like as I get older it's
not really lucrative so
it's an expensive lesson to learn yeah
it's a 90 000 lesson okay what are you
doing now for work
you working full-time uh
uh yes yes I'm working full-time I work
as
um I work with with with
individuals with intellectual
disabilities
um
do you like that word that's what I'm
doing uh yes
it's okay uh it's it's okay definitely
not something I would I see myself doing
long term I mean I love helping people
but that's not something I see myself
doing why let me ask you this um and
know this like in counseling the the why
are you you never asked that question
but I am asking that question now okay
why aren't you working in business why
aren't you using that degree that you've
paid every drop of Blood Sweat and soul
you've got for why aren't you leaning
into how to run a business how business
Works how business doesn't work the ups
and downs what's keeping you out of that
uh could I have it uh yeah graduated yet
uh who cares who cares have you looked
at the job LinkedIn man go talk to a
bunch of photographers most of them
never even went to college they don't
have a bachelor's degree yeah yeah and
they're running very successful
businesses well what what's your income
right now
uh my income is about 45 000 a year okay
what other debt do you have other than
the student loans
uh I have a thousand dollars in a
student uh I have a thousand dollar uh
credit card that it also have a a seven
thousand dollar uh car loan that
okay and that's it so you've got close
to 100 Grand in Consumer Debt
yes are you single
oh yes I'm single okay and are you
renting right now
oh I actually own my property you do own
it so you got a mortgage as well
no not uh just be bills
so it's paid for
yes oh okay what's it worth
I think it's about uh I think it's about
sixty thousand I think it's about over
sixty thousand the house is worth 60.
yeah about yes wow and is this in the
Philadelphia area is it a mobile home or
is it a single family
a single family they'll go home
okay
well
one piece of this equation is getting
your income up because staring at a pile
of ninety thousand dollars in debt when
you make 45 I can understand how you
feel overwhelmed
yeah
and are you making payments on the
student loans are they still deferred
because you're in school
uh yes they're still deferred but I'm
still in school okay but this is going
to be a rude awakening when these
payments kick back up
yeah yeah I know I know I'm trying to
repair before it actually happens uh I'm
excited to graduate in January and six
months while since I graduate in
September is six months after September
I will be paying student loan so I want
to make sure I'm prepared and I'm in the
right position so I can pay them off
I love that well it's gonna take getting
your income up have you already paid for
the rest of the semesters
you said you're in it through January
yes
yes okay so it's paid for there's no
more student loan debt you could get
into
no okay
man I there's two things you can do with
money you can spend less of it or make
more of it
and here's the deal you one of the
cornerstones to getting well one of the
cornerstones to help changing your
mental illness one of the cornerstones
of our healing from mental illness one
of course doesn't get out of debt is
owning reality here's where I'm at
here's a little hole I've got right and
so and then deciding I'm willing to do
whatever it takes to to get out
so working with people with special
needs I've done that for years it's
exhausting and tiring work right it's
hard you picked a lot of you and what
George and I are going to tell you to do
is either
keep doing that job and then as soon as
you're done grab a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich that you've made at home
and as you head to your next job that
you're going to do until 10 or 11 at
night and you're gonna get up next
morning and do it again so that you're
making 80 000 over the course of a year
or 75 or 90 or you know 78 80 85 000 a
year or you gotta find another job where
you're working in business
nearer towards what you want to do for
the rest of the years do this Frank ask
Frank where Frank wants to be five years
from now and begin to reverse engineer
that now do you want to work for a
business you work for a company do you
want to own your own place and if so you
got to learn how business Works start
looking for jobs that are going to get
you in the door there and learn how
business Works you've got an MBA uh
you're gonna know all about business but
you're not going to know how business
runs and works and feels and keeps you
up at night and all that until you
actually get in there and do it
um let me ask you this
what's holding you back
there's something there's something that
you just won't put the gas pedal all the
way to the floor what is it
uh mainly because I don't really know
how to budget money I don't know uh how
how to lose money uh I don't really know
how money Works uh that's why I watch a
lot of these Ramsey uh shows because I'm
trying to learn how how to like how to
budget my money and how to be effective
with my money instead of just wait we
can help you with that part Frank I'm
gonna gift you one year of every dollar
that's our budgeting tool the premium
version as well as one year Financial
Peace University that's going to give
you the money education they never
taught you in school but that's only one
piece of the equation the other piece is
you and what you're doing to increase
that income my goal for you is to become
debt free in two years but what that's
going to take is you making 90k a year
and paying down 45 a year you see the
math on that
yeah hustling hustling hustling and by
the way this isn't the rest of your life
you're going to go at a pace for the
next two years that you can't sustain
for the rest of your life that's not
what we're proposing
but we're our we are proposing that dude
you have dug yourself a hole and there's
a lion in the bottom of that pit and you
got to run as fast as you can over the
next 24 or 36 months are you in
I'm in I love it okay go watch those
first few lessons of Financial Peace
University you're going to learn how to
budget you're going to learn about the
debt snowball method to get out of this
pile and you're going to call us back
when you're debt free that's all we ask
in exchange for these gifts hang on the
line Jenna's gonna pick up we'll gift
that to